oh he's doing I'm enjoying my time with
this man let me get in on this oh that's
you're an officer now mister okay but
now there's no one does no one want my
valuable services Oh is everyone dying
no oh my god gone into a church I wanted
to make it a cool party yeah Booker's on
the way no well you could have some
sacramental wine but that's all right
thank you thank you you know oh thank
you he was being a problem murderer in
fact
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I can never hit anyone with a gun so
what doesn't matter anyway listen I'm
kilo I'm innocent
I promise I don't think he's kilo oh
there's another kilo i kilo I don't
think he's kilo either I kid Oh what was
that
oh wow that was creepy did someone fart
okay okay I'm assuming that's you echo
over there yeah I'm sitting down the
piano playing the music oh it's me I
don't know yeah you're pretty bad really
yeah you're pretty bad yeah let's keep
facing that way Jack are you terrorist
whatever hi mark it's not a terrorist
it's a traitor oh that's right sorry
yeah I'm Jack are you the traitor yeah
there you go Romeo
who's ooh where's my Juliet I'm kilo no
i'm kilo that's a paella it's up to you
to determine who kilo is kilo kilo now
tell me why I should spare you because
my name is kilo well that's a lie never
mind you know myself in the Piranha pool
you know what I'm gonna go feed myself
to this dog oh we know you brought on
the wrath I think that dog killed me oh
I'll get a knife and totally pulled it
on me oh sure yeah it's true
it's very true yeah from you murderers
he fell down
but there was ghosts who killed who no
one who killed mark killed me I didn't
kill no one he's Oscar and Mark is the
murderer
who are you I am Quebec I'm running away
from Bob the murderer come on Jack
uh-huh no I don't think that's right
what art broke my legs Jack watch out
mmm Bob what are you doing you don't
even know who I am I am Quebec no you're
awesome would you be a sneaky Bob oh
[Laughter]
okay there we go crisis averted Jesus
have you ever accidentally worn a green
shirt and then just a floating head
I'm papa I saw you first so I am now
your servant whatever you want
no I'm serving I'm serving I'm okay I'll
take over for you Bob you've been
working hard I know sir I just press B
to blow I am on mation be spending so
much time on each other you know amico I
think I only need one servants Oh
right now shut up oh wait it's just mark
left here's what I run that he's never
gonna hit me yeah whatever [ __ ] what do
you mean what do you mean he's crazy
I'm dancing with my body right now
perfectly sane
it's swinging me around by my hair oh
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go rub up against the piranha
okay the Piranha skulls oh yeah everyone
everyone hop in the piranha skulls so
it's after midnight right there don't
don't what do they turn into gremlins or
so kill me I'm the only one who survived
that huh don't kill me ank you please I
got hungry go yank you don't kill me
please kill me
Bravo bye stay back oh wait
statistically you probably aren't the
murderer behind doesn't mean that I like
you Victor help big act Oh Bravo answer
the phone jack get out here this goes to
kill him oh my god go into my favorite
hiding spot on this map you hop in the
shower
I'm naked I don't know they call them in
Ireland but this is a shower in America
for a long time person I've ever seen we
only have seven days to live in it let's
make the most of it get on the bed a
shower and shag Wow oh no no cheerio get
in the shower with me everybody helping
them American shower everyone up in the
douche I don't keep telling me zoom in
but I can't you're not the man I thought
you were are you one of those Irish
people that can curse really creatively
yes oh hi Wow friend okay friends
everywhere I didn't kill this guy down
here no why would you think
No
yeah you know you're going away I'm
right by the dogs why is no one by the
dog hang on I'll be there in a second
Bob I'm gonna join you cuz I can't find
anybody
I've not seen wandering around by myself
like this so you're going on toes Bob
I'm coming to find you
well I'm at the piranhas I'm on my way
we're all going to the friends sounds
like a really cool bar way no one's at
the piranhas Bob where are you I met the
Perot oh okay yeah yeah I was fighting
for safety oh my god hey there
oh please say that me and we're gonna
choose one person he'll mark to the
pronto no look I dance it's all right
where did my blind person go oh hello
hey tango tell me when you can see again
okay yeah I can't see again why am i
blind
you shot an innocent bystander my dude
you know I I'm just saying I don't let
you go and pick up a gun but we wait for
a while yes you can if you can find a
gun in the next 10 seconds oh it might
have been too long about time period
there you see
[Applause]
[Music]